[Music]
what's going on guys believe it or not
the fifth installment of the Pirates of
the Caribbean franchise is hitting
theaters if you're like me a lot of
those movies start to run together and
you forget was this person in that movie
or this movie and this becomes like a
mishmash of sword fighting swashbuckling
hi-c adventure and squid face guys so
today we're going to walk you through
some of the important characters some of
the main plot points and some of the
stuff you might have forgotten as we get
you reacquainted with the Pirates of the
Caribbean
first up the curse of the Black Pearl it
starts with a young Elizabeth Swann
finding a boy floating at sea the boy's
name well dinner
Elizabeth steals a gold pirate medallion
from the boy flash to the present
Elizabeth has grown into Keira Knightley
and will into Orlando Bloom and they are
like totally are into each other we're
then introduced to none other than
Captain Jack Sparrow
there's my intention to commandeer one
of these ships raid pillage plunder and
otherwise bill from all Weasley black
contests Elizabeth is kidnapped and
taken to gnarly pirate captain Barbosa
who reveals the crew stole cursed Aztec
gold you bestowed for these ghost
stories turn your N one in order to with
the curse Barbosa needs to return all
the gold along with the blood of
everyone who stole it and Elizabeth has
the last coin will teams up with Jack to
save Elizabeth Jack goes to recruit his
old crew including Zoe Saldana who I bet
you forgot was in this movie Jack wants
a revenge against Barbosa for staging a
mutiny and taking a ship the Black Pearl
or Bosa tries to break the curse but
discovers it's Will's blood that he
actually needs the black pearl chases
after wills and there's a big sea battle
with canons sword fighting guys swinging
from boat to boat on ropes classic
pirate shenanigans Barbosa grabs the
gold piece and will and Maroons Jack for
a second time Elizabeth sets a big fire
and gets them rescued by the Royal Navy
but Jack only cares about one thing why
is the rum gone Elizabeth gets the Navy
to go on a rescue mission for will in
exchange for a promise to marry British
officer
Commodore Norrington aka Commodore
boring ttan jackin does his double-cross
of will buy redouble crossing Barbosa
just as his crew attacks the English
ship jackscrew double-crosses everyone
and escapes with the Black Pearl
Jack steals a gold coin so that he can
be a cool skeleton too and everyone
fights a lot Sparrow shoots Barbosa
right as will cuts his hands and drops
the last pieces in the chest lifting the
curse Barbosa doesn't get an apple and
the rest of our BOCES crew surrenders to
boring ttan Jack is sentenced to be
hanged for piracy but we'll save him
Jack sails away on the Black Pearl
Elizabeth declares her love for will and
they totally make out Dead Man's Chest
its will and Elizabeth's wedding day and
what are they getting as a gift why a
death sentence from Lord Beckett yet
another stiff British guy without a
sense of humor because they set Captain
Jack free at the end of the last movie
that get agrees to let will and
Elizabeth go if will tracks down Jack
Sparrow and retrieves his weird magic
compass back on the Black Pearl Captain
Jack is just reminding his audience of
his catchphrases was rum always gone
when he's visited by bootstrap bill
Will's father who's kind of sorta live
but super Barnacle faced it seems that
Captain Jack made a deal with squid
faced ocean legend Davy Jones years ago
and if Jack doesn't pay up Davy Jones
will release the car wrong movie but yes
he will release the Kraken will tracks
Jack to an island full of cannibals and
everybody kind of runs around for half
an hour until they escape Jack agrees to
give will his compass if will help them
find a key this is where things start to
get complicated they go to meet a voodoo
priestess named Tia Dalma who explains
that the key unlocks a chest containing
Davy Jones's heart which he cut out
after a failed love affair Jack meets up
with Davy Jones who agrees to release
him from his debt if he signs up 100
souls to take his place
on the crew including will shocking no
one Jack sells his friend out
immediately yep I'm good with it so now
will is on the Flying Dutchman and Jack
is in Tortuga
poor unfortunate souls when he meets
Elizabeth who both escaped captivity and
it's gotten pardons from Lord Beckett
jack tells Elizabeth that will is on the
flying dutchman and the best way to save
him is to get the chest with Davy
Jones's heart since
whoever controls his heart controls his
actions in order to find him he gives
her his compass which points toward
whatever its holder wants most and what
Elizabeth wants most is to save will
hence it points towards the chest
oh and Commodore Borinquen humiliated
after Jack's escape in the first movie
overhears all this and decides to go
after the chest - are you still with me
just because we're just getting started
back on the Flying Dutchman will steals
the key to Davy Jones's heart chests and
promises will free is dad everyone
converges on the island where the chest
is buried and Jack will and Norrington
have a three-way duel will wants to
destroy the heart and Jones to free his
father Jack needs it to call off the
Kraken
Norrington wants to bring it back to
Beckett to get his life back in order
it's total chaos with everyone fighting
everyone there's like a giant hamster
wheel for some reason and during this
mess Norrington that sneaky little son
of a [ __ ] snags the heart and runs away
under the guise of creating a
distraction just as everyone is about to
get away the flying dutchman pops from
under the water and sets loose the
Kraken on the Black Pearl will creates a
huge bomb and Elizabeth distracts jack
so she can chain them to the deck
because the English Jack heroically gets
eaten Davy Jones opens up the chest to
discover the heart is missing shock
cut the Beckett's office the heart of
Davy Jones oh man
Beckett is like the worst guy out of all
of these people Elizabeth and will end
up back at Tia Damas mourning the loss
of Captain Jack and the Pearl Tia says
there is a way to get him back but they
must travel to the World's End not the
name of the next movie and there's only
one man who can lead them there
let's go Mike so he was just like
waiting upstairs so he can make a
dramatic entrance and now we're on to
the almost incomprehensible mess that is
at World's End Beckett this guy's hang
in any and all pirates he finds even kid
pirates no because he s Davy Jones under
his control
just like Viola Davis controlled
enchantress on Suicide Squad right that
computes Elizabeth and Barbosa go to
Singapore to request a ship and a crew
from thanks the pirate rule to Singapore
unfortunately will gets caught stealing
navigational charts to find Davy Jones's
Locker aka the land of the dead Barbosa
flips to McCoy and demands that as one
of the nine pirate Lords he honors a
call to convene the United Nations of
pirates called the Brethren Court they
need to figure out a way to stop Beckett
and the evil East India Trading Company
if this is already too complicated you
best turn back now but that's not what
they're really after what is it you seek
in Davy Jones locker Jack's mouth he's
one of the pirate Lords turns out Jack
holds one of the nine Pieces of Eight
these are the entry tokens to the
Brethren Court and he didn't pass it on
before he passed on guess what everybody
wants now British soldiers burst in will
pull suicide admits that his real goal
isn't Jack Sparrow or the pirate
brethren crap I need to blacktop between
my father
everyone escapes Elizabeth will Barbosa
they set sail with the maps to Davy
Jones locker who's also there Tia Dalma
because someone at Disney believes that
you can never have too many characters
Barbosa and company go over a sea cliff
and the movie itself goes off the
defence as we enter what I can only
describe as a Johnny Depp acid flashback
but not the fun kind like in your
Loathing in Las Vegas
there's a whole bunch of Jack Sparrow's
they shoot each other stab each other
one of them acts like a chicken but uh
there's a goat for some reason then the
rocks all turn into crabs and carry the
ship away someone approved all of this
Barbosa and the crew wash up on the
beach and find Jack almost immediately I
just had to get me mama Jack as they set
sail for the real world will is still
kind of butthurt that Elizabeth made out
with Captain Jack until she reveals that
she did it to distract him and force him
to sacrifice himself but now will his
butt hurt that Elizabeth didn't tell
about it beforehand
I'm butthurt that there's another
subplot in this movie anyway as they
sail away they passed the dead who are
arriving one of which is Elizabeth's dad
the high Sparrow Oh
before he sails away he passes along
some exposition that if Davy Jones died
someone must take his place to ferry the
dead to the other side Dutchman must
have a captain finally Captain Jack and
the Black Pearl returned to the real
world only to get ambushed by south
fangs who had an agreement to give the
pearl to will so he could save his
father double-cross I think now I've
watched this film multiple times and I
still can't tell you exactly what
happens next but to make a very long
story short Elizabeth is handed over to
South Fang and the Black Pearl heads to
Pirates Cove to convince the pirate
Lords to release conniption a powerful
sea goddess who's been trapped in human
form
since betraying her lover Davy Jones
that's right Calypso is the reason he
cut his heart out and the voodoo
priestess Tia dama is Calypso she
brought Barbosa back to life on board
his ship South thinks Elizabeth is
actually Calypso and tries to get
physical with her but the Dutchman
attacks before things get wildly
inappropriate for a Disney movie Bao is
killed but gives her his peace of eight
making her a pirate lord and a member of
the Brethren Court South ship is taken
by Davy Jones and Will's dad tells
Elizabeth that he can only be saved if
someone kills Davy Jones
but whoever kills Davy Jones must take
his place as the cat
the Dutchman and can only go ashore once
every ten years
Oh pygmy I wouldn't pick that guy either
Norrington fries Elizabeth and her crew
from the brig and bootstrap bill kills
Norrington yay will who was knocked off
the Black Pearl by Jack but not before
getting his magic compass winds up with
Beckett on the Dutchman and they
revealed a pirate's plan to free calypso
to Davy Jones who flips out will strikes
a deal you will free my son and you will
guarantee let's go safely
he will lead them to the Pirates Cove
using the magic compass they agree but
Jones has won aggressively pronounced
condition colored mug duck finally we're
at the Brethren Court which is made of
pirate Lords that are all uncomfortable
cultural stereotypes and Keith Richards
everyone presents their Pieces of Eight
which are really just pieces of junk why
not just cut that part out so we can
make this whole thing a little shorter
and less confusing Elisabeth shows up
revealing that she's taken south fangs
place on the Brethren court and that
Beckett is on the way there now with
Davy Jones in tow
Barbossa wants to free Calypso and start
an all-out war but no one can agree what
to do turns out only the Pirate King can
declare war
according to the official pirate code
for a group of literal lawbreakers he's
sure got a lot of rules to follow why
are they so obsessed with bureaucracy
anyway they all go through the Pirate
King should be and every pirate votes
for himself except Jack Elizabeth swung
now she's the pirate king and guess what
a dude we're at war
Elizabeth rallies the troops and finally
the battle begins complete with a
massive whirlpool Jack steals Davy
Jones's heart and the two have an epic
duel will and Elizabeth declare their
undying love and Barbosa marries them in
the middle of the battle
right finally jack will and Elizabeth
have a showdown with Davy Jones jack has
joins his heart but before he can do
anything
Jones stabs will bootstrap bill don't
like that one bit and he attacks Jones
Jack helps will to stab Jones's heart
killing Davy Jones but saving will who
is now the immortal captain of the
Dutchman the Dutchman disappears into
the whirlpool Jack and Elizabeth escaped
to the Pearl and the Dutchman reappears
under Will's command and saved the day
everyone throws their hats we'll now has
one day ashore before 10 years at sea as
the captain of the Dutchman of course he
uses it to do all kinds of things with
Elizabeth a gay mrs. Turner
on a secluded sandy beach he gives her
his heart and heads to see Jack is
abandoned by Barbosa once again as he
takes the Black Pearl to search for the
Fountain of Youth only to find that the
map has been taken by guess ooh Jack
Sparrow
yup a holiday show and that takes us to
the fourth film of the franchise on
Stranger Tides
we kick things off as Jack is brought
before the King of England to help them
find the Fountain of Youth
before the Spanish do jack is then
reunited with Barbosa who now is a real
goofy wig and a peg leg
Jack makes a daring escape leaping out a
window and into a carriage and hey is
that Dame Judi Dench
Jack teams up with his former fling
Angelica and sets off to find the
Fountain of Youth with Barbosa in hot
pursuit turns out that Angelica is the
first mate of the Queen Anne's Revenge
captained by Blackbeard and crewed by
this franchise's third set of undead
officers go to the well a bit much
turns out Angelica is Blackbeard's
daughter Jack tries to take over
Blackbeard's ship and failed so he pulls
a double-cross whoa a double-cross in a
pirates movie and tries to warn
Blackbeard that Angelica is lying and
actually against him but Blackbeard
won't here he wants none of it he makes
a voodoo doll of Jack to ensure his help
later that night Jack dances with
Angelica and gets her to tell him
the ritual for the fountain and that the
years you gain from it have to come from
someone else
teachers Elias McMahon Angelica also
shows Jack Blackbeard's collection of
ships in bottles real ships that he's
miniaturized with his sea powers
including the Black Pearl they arrive at
Whitecap Bay home of the mermaids who
look like supermodels but are secretly
like vampire cannibals spider-men
nevertheless they manage to bag one what
follows is a very convoluted story about
hunky priests fish tails turning into
human legs chalices Spaniards and
mermaid tears but what you really need
to know is that Barbosa isn't there for
the Fountain of Youth he's there for
revenge on Blackbeard for taking the
Pearl and the to team up Jack Barbosa
and Blackbeard arrive at the Fountain of
Youth and much swordplay ensues as they
squabble over mermaid tears and chalices
Blackbeard has Barbosa cornered but then
the Spanish arrived and declare only God
can grant eternal life not this big on
water Barbosa uses the distraction to
stab Blackbeard with a poisoned sword
before stealing Blackbeard's sword and
making a getaway
Angelica gets cut on the sword - and now
both of them are dying jack sets up the
Fountain of Youth ritual and Blackbeard
takes a drink from the cup that gives
life but double-cross of course Jack did
the old Princess Bride switcheroo and
gave him the cup that takes life
Blackbeard ends up being melted pretty
gruesomely by the fountain and Angelica
is saved by the life-giving cup the
hunky free swims off with the mermaid
presumably to live out some kind of
reverse splash scenario Jack Maroons
Angelica Barbosa takes over Blackbeard
ship and Jack reunites with his old pal
gives who's taken Blackbeard ships and
bottles including the Black Pearl
well that was fun and a valuable public
service also I need a nap after all
those movies what we leave out and how
would you rank these for pirate movies
tell us in the comments section below we
want to know I want to thank you for
setting sail with screen junkies today
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye
[Music]